-Our next guest is a talented
actress you know from iconic
films like "Dirty Dancing"
and "Ferris Bueller's Day Off."
Her memoir, "Out of the Corner,"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
Jennifer Grey, everybody!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I am far too intimidated to try
to dance with you, Jennifer.
-You Know, baby.
-Yes?
-It's all about just connection.
-Okay.
-And you just feel it,
and then it just does you.
-Okay.
-Because I didn't plan that.
-No, it just came to you.
-Just bubbled. Just bubbled out.
-So, dancing has always --
I mean, I imagine you have
a very loving relationship
with dance.
-I have a very interesting
relationship with dance.
I don't know,
do any of you guys dance?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's the same people
who never got COVID.
[ Laughter ]
Crossover, yeah.
-Well, the thing is,
is if you love to dance,
you have to dance.
-And if you're not
a good dancer,
it doesn't [bleep] matter.
-Okay, interesting.
[ Laughter ]
I want to ask about this.
So, you write a memoir,
and obviously a lot of elements
of your life.
You went back to old diaries.
Was this something -- Were you
a diarist your whole life?
-It just sounds disgusting,
"diarist."
-I know, I'm sorry.
-Blah.
[ Laughter ]
-A journalist?
That's worse, yeah.
-Okay, I don't know.
All I know is that I wrote from
when I was 14 till I was 41.
And I wrote, you know,
for myself.
I wrote just to dump out
whatever I was feeling
because we didn't have
cellphones.
We didn't have --
couldn't call anyone.
You couldn't even,
like, pull up a movie.
It was just, like, you.
And so then I just felt like I
needed to talk to someone.
-You're talking like
you grew up in 1920.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm telling you,
when I was
in the horse and buggy,
clippity-clop, very hard to --
No, I mean, literally,
we didn't have the option
to call someone to say,
"I need to talk."
So I would just download
how I was feeling,
and it was usually about a boy
or feeling just so excited
about a crush or devastated
about having things gone wrong.
You know, I wasn't writing about
world peace or, you know,
curing cancer, but I was very
consumed with my emotional life
and I felt very alone.
But then I had this listener
that was just very patient.
And I just wrote,
and I wrote from 14 to 41.
And it's weird
because I never read them.
-Oh, wow.
-Until I started the memoir.
I had them in this box and they
just traveled with me
from whatever location,
like New York, L.A.,
wherever I was living,
this trunk.
And I pulled them up,
and they just smelled musty,
as you can imagine, like, "ugh."
And then I'm seeing, and it's
the same person from 14 to 41.
Like, I thought
I would have matured.
[ Laughter ]
I thought I would have
learned something.
But it's the same thing because
it's like the essence,
like the really inner voice that
is unedited,
and it's just the same.
And it's just,
the only difference is it got
a little more dramatic
and the, you know,
handwriting got really sloppy.
[ Laughter ]
Like, towards the end.
-Yeah, that's the first thing
to go, the handwriting.
-The first page is always like,
"Oh, this is the new me.
I am going to be writing with
this perfect calligraphy."
And at the end, you're just
like, "Grrrr!"
[ Laughter ]
-So, "Out of the Corner"
obviously references
a very famous line
in a very famous movie.
Was there any sense
that you were
taking the line back
for yourself?
Because, you know, it's belonged
to everybody else
ever since "Dirty Dancing"
came out.
-Well, it was -- I noticed there
was an irony about the fact that
if I died, it would be like,
"Okay, she's finally
out of the corner."
Or, like, I don't know what they
would say, but it would --
-What newspaper?
[ Laughter ]
"Jennifer Grey, out of corner
in a coffin."
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, "she's out of the corner,
good."
You know, there's just
something -- I just, you know,
I've noticed that there's
a little mean-spiritedness
in the world, and everyone's
looking for just a flashy thing.
And I thought, "What if I'm
known to be the girl
that nobody puts me
in the corner?"
And as I was writing my stories,
high points, low points,
kind of the things that made me
who I am, really,
those things shape you,
especially the hard things,
especially the really hard
things.
They just do something.
They change you.
And then I thought, "Wait a
minute, there's a lot of stories
where I'm feeling
put in a corner."
And then I thought,
"That's so gross."
Like, "I don't want to be
that girl."
And I thought,
"Well, how did I get there?"
And then, once I took away
all blame and all shame
and I just tried to be as honest
as if I was a detective
or a scientist, you know, just
laying out a forensics table,
just to get really cheerful...
[ Laughter ]
...and what I noticed was that,
yes, things happen to everybody.
Life is messy. It's complicated.
We mess up.
Other people mess up.
We fall in love.
We fall out of love.
But the truth is, I saw the ways
in which I was colluding with,
like almost sleeping with
the enemy.
The way I was agreeing
with them.
They betrayed me.
I betrayed myself.
I picked them.
I stayed with them.
I did all of these things
because I couldn't do better
at the time.
And then I went, "What if --
If I put myself there,
then I can take myself out."
And that is what this book did
for me, is it helped me
look at all of my stories that
I've been telling my whole life.
You know how we have the stories
we're born with,
our families have told us?
They're just -- We accept
that they're just facts.
And then I realized there's a
lot of things that weren't true.
-That must've been incredibly
cathartic to work through.
-It was just revelatory because
I realized that I can change
my story, and so can we all.
And I just think everyone should
do it just because
it's an opportunity to give
yourself a better life.
-Well, that's a really
nice thing
that you did for yourself,
I think.
-I feel very happy about it.
I mean, I don't know, I just
feel like they should teach it
in school -- how to tell your
truth without blame or shame.
-I want to close
with one final thing.
You had a friendship,
and I think this dates when
the friendship is from,
because you have Polaroids
of it.
-Correct, yeah.
-But this is you and Madonna.
Now, did you reach out to
Madonna before
you wrote the book and say,
"Hey?"
-Well, I didn't reach out for
permission or anything, no.
-Okay, gotcha.
You just gave her a heads-up.
-That would be silly.
No, I reached out to her
afterwards.
I said, "Hey, I wrote about you
in my book,"
because we were
really, really wild
and had incredible fun times.
And I remember, every time
I would hear the song
"Express Yourself," I would
remember her saying to me,
"Hey, get in my car. I just
recorded a song. Come here."
And I said, "Why in your car?"
"'Cause my sound system is
better. Get in my car."
And we sat in my driveway, and
she played "Express Yourself,"
and she said, "It was inspired
by what I want you to know,
what I think you should do."
-That's really lovely.
-By my breakup
and by what she believed.
You know how we believe better
lives for each other?
-Mm-hmm.
-And I wrote to her
in the e-mail recently, I said,
"Did you just say that
to everyone?"
[ Laughter ]
So, when she wrote me back,
she didn't say anything,
so either she didn't read
the whole e-mail...
[ Laughter ]
She was just like, "Yeah."
-I think that's confirmation.
"it's only about you.
It's only about you."
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations on the book.
Jennifer Grey, everybody!
"Out of the Corner"
is available now.